foreign
[Music]
I'm not go ahead go ahead lay it on me
thanks for the coffee you're welcome
it's not good you know why oh I know why
you think that no because it's a very
good coffee place and you have taste
into everything that there ever is sleep
those out because it's the first all
right I can't say that I'm sorry I was
passionate it's all right just leave
them out
it's not good pod podcast it's not good
calling so far dude first of all that
coffee from and the name will we won't
say the name because well I love it I
want to say the name but we don't say
the name because of how I I think it's
it's really bad and it and people think
it's really good it is really good it's
Alfred's okay well you just said you
wanted to know that's gonna be the joke
and you kind of ruined it by saying I
will say the number because of the name
because I liked him no but I didn't know
no no you know what the thing is you're
pissing me off is the main overarching
thing the coffee is good no on top of
that you're pissing me off because I was
saying the coffee's bad no because you
said I messed up the bid even though I
didn't well the bit was messed up a
little bit I saved it because I'm good
with bits I think so it's fine I think
you messed it up but by doing it in the
first place because it wasn't that great
listen for the the cold brew at Alfred's
coffee
but who cares because only losers
luddites and Lemmings get cold brew
well that's not true yeah it is real
people who with real tastes get what
real coffee
okay dude I drink four shots of espresso
over ice okay I really I really do I
really do all the cool stuff dude when
it comes to Coffee I drink I drink
regular coffee sometimes okay then
you're doing great when you do that okay
remember the guy at Indian guys who
drink something like this and we always
made fun of them
no oh damn no I would love to remember
that
no he was like of some sort of Asian
descent it was New Jersey still I was so
young no I don't remember that okay well
dude oh you don't cherish our youth as
much as I do well no but there do you
remember the guy that was in a baseball
camp and we called him Dart head
yeah Kramer his name is Kramer he was
yeah his name his last name was Kramer
dude he had a turban on which is cool
we're not you know but and that sounds
racist well no Kramer's a different guy
obviously a guy named Kramer wasn't
wearing a turban but keep going in So
yeah so
this guy was not Kramer no I know
because he would wear it wear the turban
he would wear his baseball hat over the
turban he couldn't fold the brim like
that so it was so straight like we said
straight like a dart so we'd call him
Dart head and now realizing that it
probably sounds very racist
I think someone if we said it the wrong
way too fast it would sound like dot
head oh that would be racist didn't even
think about that for 25 years neither
until 30 years me neither until right
now wow interesting so the point is
we're not racist well the point is is
the cold brew from Alfred's is very bad
and so is the coffee I wouldn't know
because I only drink real delightful
Brew okay worst actual delightful Brew
okay so foreign this is delightful Brew
yeah uh listen uh it's not good I've
been there plenty of times I know real
coffee I drink real coffee I love coffee
have you had their world famous vanilla
latte bro a vanilla latte is right now
if a vanilla latte is not good then the
place should be it should explode
very many places should should yeah they
should fly through and bomb another
place that's crazy a vanilla latte
should only be your drink you go wow
that's amazing
the world famous Alfred is this world
famous you know how I know that because
they menu it says world famous bro I
could I mean I did this in quotes not
because I did it Alfred is it even in
another place Alfred
Alfred's coffee why are you acting like
Mom adding an S mom does do that but
even to things that have an S at the end
she has because it's Alfred's coffee
it's his Alfred's is called Starbucks's
coffee yeah that's yeah anyway let's
move on because it's not it's really not
that good but let's move on you love it
fine I got you that hat you're welcome I
was just gonna say thanks for that even
though you did nothing to get it it was
all Kristen
yeah but I know you so I know so you
didn't have four star on the bit but you
did have foresight on that yes I had
nothing to do with it but she told me
she was gonna do it and I said oh that's
cool so in a way I did have something to
do with it because if I if I said I
don't think that's a good idea I would
put the kibosh on it so you're welcome
in that way do we all know who that is
that's your uh your your dog yeah yeah
my dog Charlie your dog Charlie
tell us are you it was like this too are
you gonna have that coffee
go ahead have it and he's got the
Carhartt hat because he's a working man
he would like regular coffee like you
know
is Carhart working man [__] that's what
they say but I said a bad word again
that's okay it's four minutes in
whatever but you know I'm I'm good with
it but you swear a lot so I do yeah but
you messed it up the last episode
no don't do that so look so you're
walking for the Hat
so it was for Christmas I finally came
yeah you know and I gotta be honest yeah
it is do you actually really do you
actually like it I feel like you would
not like this no I like it yeah I
thought it was too small because I tried
it on she thought I was going to be too
small I tried it on and it was fine it's
snug but it's not too small cool got it
why she said you should get we were at a
place and she was like you should get
mad that that uh beanie and I looked at
I didn't think you'd like it and it
wasn't this it was no it was um a
tie-dyed more uh it's like purple pink
kind of one but it was not like thick it
was thin I don't like thin okay I knew
it yes dude yes he knows his brother
dude I don't like thin I know my brother
yeah you do and that in that instance
you know I know my brother very well so
uh so yeah so anyway dude
um that was that was how I feel about
that that's great it's great
good
[Laughter]
I quit
what percent of people do you think know
what that is
one
no way no no no it's more way less no
we're less than one no it's more okay
hold on a second before before we tell
you what it is yeah in the comments be
truthful because I'm gonna look this
time I never look but I'm gonna look
this time
do you know
what this is from
I quit
I quit and then and then he says I quit
oh this might give it away but why not
and last the third one he says I quit Mr
White I quit you know and he said
there's my give it away but and then he
goes like this
I quit Tom hanks's character in that
thing you do so uh yeah dude it's from
that thing you do and it's like oh can
we play it play it yeah dude play it
dude legendary play it play it
it's not legendary it is look how many
views
a quarter quarter million
I
I quit so dick you know yeah the laugh
the laugh
I quit Mr White
oh he doesn't add another uh I I failed
dude no you know what happened for sure
and we know this because we're in the
biz right okay but for sure that he did
it and the director said you know what I
want I want after you're done doing it I
want you to take an actual moment where
you really talk to him like a person
that's what he said dude and you know
who the director was
Tom Hanks slash Mr White slash the
writer dude Tom hanks's writing and
directorial debut is that Thing You Do
so direct another movie called Larry
crown
what are you doing Tom Hanks well I
don't understand why anybody wants to do
anything but the thing they do
well put that on my Tombstone if you're
gonna do something like crazy and wild
go for it do something if your Tom Hanks
right and you want to do some like crazy
like sex thriller or something yeah
write it direct it be in it even if
you're talking don't do some stupid
light romantic comedy don't do something
that Tom Hanks would get cast as an
actor to do when he was young before he
even made it you know like that's like
what that thing you do is for him it's
also like what Larry Larry Crown do you
know what it is yeah it's terrible yeah
with his legs out like this like right
yeah with Julia Roberts on the back he's
like this like that guy dude if he
wasn't Tom Hanks would ever get Julia
Roberts you know what I mean right right
right right right right right
um so yeah okay uh crystallia.com
I am going to be shooting my special
April first chrysler.com April 1st uh
and I'll be in Austin I will be in uh
Milwaukee I've got Columbus Ohio I got
Ohio days coming up
um and what else I don't even know a
different ones man different places
I want to submit a video to the show
click in the link in the description
below or go to watch lifetime.com and if
you want a private session you don't
want to air it out in front of the whole
entire world because the whole entire
world of watches this show you can make
a session with me one-on-one Mano and
mono
it travels nowhere except into my ears
it never goes out of my mouth whatever
you tell me never goes anywhere else
mattelia.com baby baby
well I was I was doing a pause to lead
up to it but yeah so wait let's go back
to this you think lifelinemerch.com for
the merch you think and the merch is
absolutely
you think that for real
crazy dude no of like of like the entire
world no no America America okay then I
would say like people in between three
and five percent Colombia be like that's
from yeah in India yeah yeah between
between three and five percent that's
that's crazy bro I mean that's probably
so wrong but I want that to be true
though so I'm sticking with it but now
if that movie had come out maybe this
year maybe you maybe one percent or two
percent even no now nobody remembers
anything from nobody remembers any lines
for movies okay fair enough you're right
there's too many of them it's an
onslaught and it's like yes I get it
it's not the same thing there's that
whole [__] like like dude the best
pictures I don't know foreign
I have no idea who they are yeah I will
never know ever again
but also [__] like green book wins [__]
like uh what was the gamer the horror
movie about the fish that she [__] yep
Fish Out of Water nobody ever thought
about that the year after it came out
Fish Out of Water no that's not what it
was called shape of water shape of water
so to Shadow Water [__] but that could
have caught a fish the shape of water is
so [__] yeah the shape of water is [__]
because the shape of water is whatever
you put it in well
there's something poetic going on in
their minds but there's no poetry going
on when you watch it because suckville
is it bad it's suckville yeah really
dude give me the Toro is that the guy
who did the [__] the cabinet of James
Gamo Del Toro on Netflix what Anthony
he's a dork yep what did you say
Guillermo del Toro did a thing called
the cat what is it called Thor Anthony
knows
Cabinet of Curiosities oh yeah if you
said the thing I wouldn't know I said
cabinet I didn't know there's a cabinet
of Guillermo del Toro
and like I was just gonna say yes he
probably did that because he is in his
kitchen
yeah yeah dude it's that thing is not
good Kristen likes that it's odd she
likes it but and he he's doing this
thing where he like introduces each
episode that's his dream that's his
dream this is the kind of filmmaker that
generally bothers me Gilbert Authority
is actually good but he's got this
quality about him that a lot of other
successful filmmakers have and all they
want to do is recreate [__] they saw
when they were eight wow that's so funny
dude like Peter Jackson with King Kong
like these guys like he even remade
actual King Kong what the hell these
guys they just want to feel like little
kids again wow not to be Chicago but
Pauline Kale's original review of
Raiders of the Lost Ark Steven
Spielberg's Raiders lost ark is the best
takedown of that and it was like what
year did that come on why do filmmakers
do that that'd be like if I wanted to
make a movie now called like the
babysitter who molested me in the TV
room ah the babysitter who hypnotized me
and I cried like a [__] my name is
Crystal here not magically because
magically didn't cry that's the title
you cried dude he cried he was getting
hypnotized and he cried first of all I
was not hypnotized I cry at that I
hypnot I cried because you were being
hypnotized and I felt bad for you and I
was traumatized by it moving on well it
didn't work
dude her name was you know remember her
name was her name was Muffy oh yeah I do
remember that Muffy sir
that was not the uh I was talking about
the babysitter that's a different I'm
joking but he was talking about the he
you're talking about the hypnotized
thing yeah yeah yeah that's the only
thing we're talking about though so
that's all good no I said the joke about
the molestation
doesn't even separate babysitters okay
uh but yeah no uh Muffy she had a white
fake white uh furry thing I think she
was an exotic dancer man no she wasn't
an exotic dancer and she also didn't
have a white furry thing you're saying
that because you think a person with
name Muffy would have that and you're
why would that be true I remember her
specific way it might be wrong but I
distinctly remember she was blonde yeah
and she was the friend of the actual
babysitter I thought she was the baby no
I thought she was a babysitter and she
brought her friend no the babysitter
brought Muffy fair enough fair enough
and Muffy was the hypnotist
such a weird shot the funny is it that
muffy's like 50 right now you know yeah
at least right she's got to be she
probably at least 50.
yeah so uh all right Muffy if you're out
there watching you should submit a video
ask should I regret trying to hypnotize
to young innocent children when it was
way out of line to do that and I
remember there were being like t blank
he blink he blinked to you and I I got
so I got scared I got scared bro I was
scared I was such a scared child yeah
I'm still scared so what was I doing
you were doing you were getting
hypnotized you're like all right I'll do
it I was like Matt you'll do it okay
cool oh what a badass I was dude you're
a badass yeah you're a badass yeah
you've been hypnotized ever since so
anyway let's get into hypnotized me to
be a badass my whole life
um you will be a badass on the count of
three one two three
all right
I need to buy another leather jacket and
then you put yeah
I'm gonna start smoking all right cool
I'm five years old all right yeah shall
we
did a magic trick in the beginning too
absolutely Hates Chris the way she said
Chris what's up Matt what's up Chris oh
Jess here from a Montreal Canada okay
well that's not what it is I'm looking
to see it should be though what you guys
would do in this situation or what you
guys do with your friend group but I've
been hanging out with the same group of
people for over a decade now we're
really close and whenever we would do
weekends away get Cottages or like
splurge
it used to kind of be Tit for Tat in
terms of like someone would make a big
dinner and spend Groceries on that
dinner then that other person would book
The Cottage and so it would kind of even
out it's called living fair but some of
her like less
financially able friend kind of get left
out sure or are you contributing the
same
and so now we have a spreadsheet and
it's really weird that's called living
room these aren't friends you work yeah
in terms of situations like that okay
friends if you have a friend yeah you
never involve them in something that
requires making a spreadsheet because no
real friends do that congratulations you
are now running a business yeah you've
got a business congratulations yeah it's
just gross feeling also it's called
living Fair the Things She Said at first
you know and then the things she said
about the spreadsheet is called living
wrong okay okay two songs that Garth
Brooks could sing and both on different
CDs yeah
and then the next one would come out
three years later called living wrong
dude
um ancient so uh yeah all right well the
what was the question like does she just
is it is it like is that wrong it's all
[__] up yeah here's the deal if you
start getting into another tax bracket
okay your other friends that aren't in
that tax bracket you're done with them
no they get a free meal you buy them
food that's how that goes if you're the
one who makes money first yeah
especially if it's a lot more money you
buy them food you never say oh should we
let's split it
you never know no you don't do that you
don't ever do that you buy two options
so there are two options then you can
either pay for everything or
you you're in a different tax bracket
you're done with those friends you've
leveled up right and and then when you
see them again because you'll still run
into them you'll go like you go like
this
oh
you know or even better like this
that's better oh yeah
uh looking leveled up in another tax
bracket who whoever started the
spreadsheet thing they that person's a
piece of [__] I'm out yeah you know and
also money with friends
that sucks you can divvy up also the the
stuff you could be like I'm paying for
everything but you guys got to stay in
the servants quarters and now when we
get the cottage it's great but you guys
are gonna be doing more chores yeah and
you make my bed yeah you bring me my
food that I bought yeah you bring it to
me in bed and when I'm done you can eat
yeah and you say it like this when
you're you go when your bed's not made
like early enough you walk out and go
what the [__] yeah and they say what you
say my bed's not made and then they go
and they go whoa oh shoot oh okay I
guess that was mine let me check the
spreadsheet and be like you don't have
to spread check the spreadsheet you're
poor yeah and then and then we'll walk
out yeah yeah
yeah so those are the good that's the
the great advice is for us but yeah the
one who made the spreadsheet
women Under the Influence dude
play the clip Play a clip of that can
you I wonder no maybe long get it maybe
long get it that's okay I know who the
character name is I know but I know
yeah
oh yeah worst producer in the game okay
yeah you know you know what it's not my
thing I'll do that all right next up
I was just wondering what your guys's
thoughts were on um like being super
competitive so one thing about me is
I've always been super competitive and
it it's like led me pretty far in life
I've succeeded at a lot of things but
also it makes people not like me
um so I was just wondering yeah thoughts
were if either of you guys are
competitive or like
if that bothers you like if that annoys
you guys if you know people who are like
that
um but yeah thank you love the podcast
see ya look being competitive is is
unfortunately a natural human animal
thing whatever so it's not like to be
competitive means you suck or anything
but
exhibiting competitiveness that
especially like an over competitive
thing that sucks and it alienates people
like if you're playing I was playing
risk yeah the other day with his friends
and I was thinking wow what if someone
was like
really compete I would not want to play
but it was so fun because no one was
like that cardboard yeah one more thing
I played an adult baseball league right
and obviously it didn't matter because
what I just said it's an adult baseball
league and it's not Major League
Baseball if it's not Major League
Baseball doesn't matter exactly so I was
pitching because I'm a pitcher I'm a
lefty I'm very good at baseball and this
uh we still live in the valley so like
okay yeah 15 years 15 years ago yeah
um and the there were two brothers on
the team one was the catcher
and one was the shortstop and they were
like the best ones okay that's sad yeah
and uh
dude like we the at home played the
opposing team somebody slid into home
plate and accidentally spiked the guy
The Catcher And the catcher comes in
right before I go out to pitch another
inning and he says this guy's coming up
the guy that spiked me hit him beat him
with the [__] fastball and I just I
paused for a second I was I was this is
exactly what happened
he said hit him like hit him with a
fastball and I and I just
no yeah
no because that like why why would I do
that and why do you even want me to do
that because he oh because he hurt you
yeah how did it hurt you clean Adam
Sandler
but that's okay hold on that's not
really competitive that is dude that's
even worse well yeah but that's more
like yeah I guess you're right I guess I
mean I get I get the competition yeah he
got so upset that it made him want to
actually hurt a person that's crazy well
that's really yeah especially like he
had already calmed down from it also
don't baseball league not the MLB right
uh I don't I I don't think you should
ever be competitive in anything but
business business is cool like because
you got to be the best business you'd be
competitive with other businesses but
like
don't ask me about my business I'm a
business man but if you are like
competitive in on anything like dude
what's up I was playing what was it not
frisbee golf
what's the one Ultimate Frisbee okay and
I was playing just having a fun I mean
it's a frisbee thing and uh one of the
guys there that I was in high school one
guys I was like yo Chris is actually way
more fun if you take it seriously oh
dude if you take anything seriously that
involves a frisbee yeah well that's what
I'm saying I go
I'm not gonna do that man check it out
I like the guy a lot but like right I'm
still friends with him it was Tom Cruise
it was Tom yes he goes like this
if you take it seriously and then he
[__] ran across the side of the
building with a with a [__] bungee
jumping on
um so foreign
yeah dude and it was just like it's like
nah I don't I don't have that the only
thing I think you should be competitive
with is if you could turn that on into
yourself be competitive with yourself
man well that's what I don't get even
about business like why do you want to
out do other business no no no you're
right except for some you know sometimes
in some business there's a there's like
a uh it's a pie you know it's like sure
I can only spice of the market exactly
the slice the market I mean not with a
comedy or anything like that right
uh you know if you're a [__] I don't
know Kleenex if you make butter in your
Lando Lakes yeah and then there's
another butter they start coming up on
you and it's like you know yeah anyway
you like Lando Lakes that's what I
always had growing up you know yeah
that's what Dad would get I don't I tell
you what I don't like well I can't
believe he's not bother well it's not
butter I know it doesn't make butter too
also yeah I totally can believe it
of a dirty person's butt can't believe
it's not bother spread remember it would
do that remember it was I Can't Believe
It's Not Butter and then it came out
with spread and they're like I can't
believe it's not bother spread no dude
it was I Can't Believe It's Not Butter
it's spray it was the spray dude it was
always spread that's disgusting right
dude that's disgusting spray you're
right there's no bother a spray You
Can't Believe It's Not Butter and it's a
spray yes you can Believe It's Not
Butter because butter you don't spray
butter yeah I totally believe this is
not butter spread can't believe it's no
bother shorts
[Laughter]
did you know that
I said yeah oh okay I can't believe it's
not bother
Transcendence you would say a spray
though I know just making stuff up
though now at this point let's watch
commercial
said nowhere we go
well that was quick she wanted to
jerking him off
but cholesterol took away their passion
until
dressed like Tupac
where's the spray can't believe it's no
bother dude let me tell you something
right now before you even play the next
one
who
who ever thought Fabio thought you know
nobody
dude he's a chick but that's not even
the reason I know I know it's ridiculous
he is ridiculous looking man his hair is
gross okay do you have this one here we
go
to her it could only be a fantasy
a lion so tasty
I Can't Believe It's Not bothered it's
great I can't even talk dude crazy dude
without any fat or calories you I Can't
Believe It's Not Butter spray it's not
just a dream any longer it says
fantasies don't come true dude that had
to do honestly 45 takes like they were
like Fabio
yeah no dude you're you're you what I
can't believe it's not spray a butter
Fabio
for you you didn't even look in the
camera and smile believe I can't spread
butter
Fabio
have you guys seen the picture of him
getting hit in the face of the bird yes
sir yes I have that is the fact that
that picture exists honestly that was
the first AI there's no way that's real
that's unbelievable life is really good
sometimes pull it up
sometimes life is really good uh the the
third uh song by what's his name he got
[__] up
oh yeah yeah look how happy the blonde
is you finally it happened the blonde
dude
I believe it's a bird
I can't believe it's a bird in my face
it wasn't it a goose yeah it was like I
can't believe it's not a bird it was a
goose yeah
I can't believe it's not a bird it's a
goose
hey 57 he got hit you can't believe it's
not a bird [__] no no okay but let's
not I mean you know what I mean that's
so rude everybody thinks he's not as
ugly he's so [__] ugly so shitty you
know he's not ugly he's just the fact
that they marketed him as that is
hilarious you know what he was he was
the guy in the romance night I know that
covers I know that because I've read
them all okay well
that's I used to smash off to the cover
falsehood he's disgusting and ugly
you listening you watching
you're ugly how much did he always sit
like this yeah cause you got hemorrhoids
you know
I can't believe it's not I Can't Believe
It's Not Just ass pain it's hemorrhoids
um all right so gross right
to the shot with the with the [__]
thing in the background brick shot like
I had one shot in there was from Barry
Lyndon you know
what a dork dude he says bird Linden of
all the [__] movies well the least
known
it's one of the best movies ever made at
least known uh life get a brain Stanley
Kubrick movie of all time your life get
a brain all right anyway next one all
right we're taking a break to tell you
about next Evo I love it oh wow Chris
loves it just saying I love it I'm Matt
and I love it uh Wellness is more than
just about nutrition uh and exercise
it's physical it's mental and you know
what it's also emotional so sleep
uh Stress Management mindfulness these
are all important aspects of wellness
and next Evo is really ma if you want to
get the next level of Wellness CBD can
help but your average CB day CBD oil
just is not going to cut it next Evo
Naturals developed smart sorb technology
clinically proven to help your body
absorb CBD four times better than
regular CBD oil because oil just doesn't
mix with your water-based body it works
faster too so when you need to distress
sleep better or recover from an intense
workout you want to reach for a next Evo
Naturals capsules gummies mints and
topical creams yeah they even got that
so uh yeah vegan GMO free gluten-free
THC free capitals and gummies dry from
U.S grown hemp the website is a joy to
use and finding the product uh to fit
your needs would you say is fantastic I
would say it is absolutely fantastic
trouble sleeping feeling anxious the CBD
next Evo really really does help and I
have problems with both of those things
huh no big deal but thanks next Evo make
CBD a part of reaching your full
potential try next Evo Naturals capsules
gummies mints and topical creams with
smart sorb technology clinically proven
to be better absorbed by your body get
20 off your first order of 40 or more at
next evo.com podcast and use promo code
Lifeline that's 20 off and n e x t e v
o.com slash podcast promo code Lifeline
thanks guys
logic hey Chris Matt Max from Victoria
BC here yeah I love it got a question
for you guys been hanging with the same
girl for about six-ish months we were
open oh boy uh things were great we
spend a lot of time together we had
great communication we talked about
everything I went on a couple dates she
talked to a couple guys but nothing
worth risking what we had cool it was
amazing
um really like this girl okay okay last
weekend she went to a show a music
festival in Seattle with a guy that I
knew about she went for four days she
[__] this guy oh so mad about it
oh sorry coming so mad about it dude
dude
[__] this guy
his ass was clenched so hard it's been
great you know it's been awesome like we
love each other and this girl's [__]
amazing rather it's all been we all know
about it you know she went to Seattle uh
for a music festival four days for this
guy [__] this guy
um and you know it's all good knew it
was gonna happen all good knew it knew
it saw it coming great great so it's
great what if that was it no no question
Sonny guys what do I do tears come out
all right keep going
uh she told me it just happened I I
don't believe that I think it was a
calculated move oh my God this guy she
also told me she was going to stay at
the hotel by herself she stayed there
with him oh that's not good oh that's a
lot she's allowed to do all this because
she is single she is open but she lied
but she's lying to me it's very
interesting though that's something I
should be worried about
um we're not talking now
I uh told her I'm kind of done for now I
didn't react the best I reacted more
upset than I should have because she is
open we are open she's allowed to do
what she wants but it hurt me more than
I thought of course apparently I like
this girl a lot yeah I could date her in
two seconds
um I don't know what to do do I just
leave it alone let her reach out she
probably won't reach out she's stubborn
as hell yeah you got to do it um love
you guys so much really Chris I've been
a fan for seven years you're the man not
you made Chris better hey you do you do
you do uh okay but but
yeah you're gonna have to do the
reaching out she's not if you blew up at
her she has every right to not reach out
anyway this guy's this guy's a cool guy
okay okay I just you know okay could
make fun of him and I wanna yeah okay
okay okay
so I got some myself but uh you
shouldn't have blown up but it's okay
because you got feelings and everybody
has feelings and we let them get the
best of us sometimes you're right that
she shouldn't have lied you're right
that you shouldn't have reacted the way
you did but you learned something and
that thing you learned is that you like
her more than you realized
just tell her all of these things
exactly and say look I would love to
actually what I realized is that I
actually do want to be in a relationship
with you I want to not be open and my
only thing is like we just need to be
honest yeah because if she told him just
that they were gonna stay in the same
hotel right he might have realized he
liked her more than Yeah
by just thinking about that right and
they could have avoided all of this to
begin with which is fine that you didn't
avoid it people [__] people and it means
nothing because like you guys could get
together tomorrow and be super [__]
happy yeah she never thinks about that
guy again but like she lied that wasn't
cool you were blew up that wasn't cool
just circle back around who gives this
[__] you're not she's no Pride involved
just [__] who cares she started it oh
wow I think you get to be mad he gets to
be mad I don't know how everybody was
mad but okay look what I don't
understand is she
was was the pretense that she wasn't
gonna [__] him because if she's going
with the guy anyway and he knew about it
even if she got separate rooms
you know they're gonna [__] he said he
knew or something like that right he
said he like was feeling like he said he
knew what was going to happen right
right right right right right so it's
confusing because
you're mad I
I understand you're you're upset that
she lied but also
I feel like he's actually really upset
because he's been lying to himself about
how he's okay with this open
relationship and didn't say anything
before she went off yeah [__] Mr
Seattle so my advice is look the reason
you say look the reason why because this
is what I think and this is what I'm
making up I think I think that because
uh
you I think that I was pretending to be
okay with this and I realized that I
caught real hard feelings for you
um and this lie made me blow up because
I was acting mad at the LIE when I was
in fact
I should have been truthful with myself
and now I'm mad that I said it was okay
for you to do this with me because
um I actually really like you and I want
to be exclusive with you and also with
the way you would set things up you only
had a right in your mind to get mad at
the things she lied about which is why
it could very well be just misdirected
anger you could just be angry that you
didn't say something earlier that you
kind of shoved your feelings down for
the sake of wanting to have have it
remain open
my point is you might be right my point
is who cares yeah what the deal is now
right is that you realize now that you
like her a lot more than you realized
yeah and that's fair wish you didn't
blow up at her for that reason right and
like let's try to start something
exclusive yeah I'm sorry I yelled all I
require really is but that's not even I
mean you should say it but it's not like
a crazy requirement honesty is the
Bedrock of honestly yeah any any good
relationship we've all [__]
not been honest at various times in our
lives but like
at least now you guys can start from
somewhere really actually foundational
and strong here's another thing too when
you're in an open relationship with
somebody why is it important for you to
know oh is she staying with him or not
like that's what I'm saying though it's
misdirected yeah it's the only here's
why it's the only thing she lied about
right so he needs to be able to get mad
about that no I understand that that's
kind of a version of what I was saying
but I'm saying when you're in a
relationship I think the rules should be
look you're gonna do you I'm gonna do me
yeah but not why are you asking so much
about it but that's the thing it doesn't
matter his point is that it's if it's
open I I reserve the right to ask
whatever I want you could still do it
yes right yes but so I'm saying I'm
saying you kind of got yourself in a
corner here to him right because but but
he's not
I get what you're saying but you can
have all kinds of open relationships I
think what you're saying is if you are
in one you wouldn't want to know
anything because I know everyone but he
is different and I think a lot of people
would be like him yes tell me exactly
what you're doing as long as I know what
you're doing
then that's fine because you have
assemblance of control yeah I just feel
like going behind your back I understand
that except for the fact that dude when
you're like things happen and when
you're having sex like it's the Heat of
the Moment and you know like what if one
of the rules was no BJs and then you're
doing you're doing the girl and the girl
does it or the one well that was one of
the rules I just wouldn't be in that
room I understand do a different one do
a different one
it's just like too it's too hard to be
like these are the rules and then this
it's like dude you have a 150 000 rules
I think well what if this is a woman
drinking what if this you know I know
people who swear by it but I just and
it's I can only say for myself open
relationships sound like the worst thing
to me I'm not saying everybody should
just be monogamous and settle down with
a single partner some people [__]
stay single whatever yeah date a lot
like go through many relationships I'm
just saying several Partners several
intimate Partners at once sounds like
just thinking about it gives me anxiety
[Music]
with seven different women why do you
say Benito when you're doing that you're
singing about a guy named Benito
Benito
Benito that's like when I do the the
what's the song these weak arms is heavy
a straw I don't know oh yeah what's that
song called Lose Yourself
it's interesting you did it once I
didn't want you to even do it that one
time but then you did it again and I
didn't extra didn't want you to do it
the second time you did it and now
you're gonna do it again do you know why
and now the most I don't want you to let
me tell you something you know how you
don't laugh at that at all and you have
a straight face when you do it when I do
it yeah you don't at all laugh at it
yeah I still look in your eyes and I do
it yeah because you have a straight face
I feel that straight face and I turn it
on its ass but I'm not but I will tell
you this one I know you're not I know
you're not trying to not yeah yeah no no
that's what I was gonna say either and
that pissed me off that you okay I was
really gonna say I'm not like
actively trying to signal to you that
I'm not liking I know that okay okay I
know don't point at me though you got
you're putting me when you're saying
I'll put it back here you're like doing
like I got I got that about you all
right across the line but you basically
did and over here now our voices are
raising and there's a reason for that my
voice is not racist because it's getting
very a lot of things about lying what
you're doing a lot of lying up right now
no no I'm just exaggerating it for
effect but let me tell what I'm saying
is the truth the reason why I can do
this stuff yeah
looking right at you why you're not
laughing the reason why I can do it and
still honestly feel okay because I'm a
[__] soldier in these streets and I'm
really good at stand up and I'm good at
stand up and when I bomb it doesn't
matter dude because I know I'm true and
I know this shit's funny so you can look
at me with straight face all you want
dude but I'll I'll tell you what I'll
either get you or I won't care that I
don't it's deeper
all right so yeah so do what we both
said anyway yeah yeah yeah yeah
my hair my hair let me just murdered
someone yeah
are you in trouble we've been together
for 15 years we have two sons together
um and we were all to dinner the other
day and we were having a good time I was
just kidding I was like do you still
think I'm hot oh boy and he was like I
wouldn't say that
and he was like you're cute like I think
you're beautiful I think you're sexy
like you know when we do [__] and he's
like but I wouldn't say that you know
you were caught why I'm like okay
weirdly caught my feelings hurt because
you're a [__] cares like I know he
loves me he tells me no no but in a way
I was just like just a little high like
this if I didn't want the answer right
like do these words even matter am I
being narcissistic like who cares but I
just want to know your opinion on that
like what is your take you guys are
[__] Aces thank you I love you so
much seriously please don't ever stop
doing what you're doing you guys keep me
sane throughout the week I look forward
to this point we appreciate you okay
but let me just say something hold on
don't lie no
she is hot she's obviously hot right so
just say yes but what he I mean I don't
mean to defend this guy but he's
obviously looking at it differently than
us this is the first time we've seen
this woman this guy's been with her for
15 years he clearly feels comfortable
enough to be like well you don't really
like get me going anymore but that's
that's [__] hell right but that's
what a heart means right I mean
obviously this is such a nuanced
conversation you don't just say I
wouldn't say that the same thing as like
do I look fat in this it's like the most
obvious don't say yes to that yeah well
yeah but also if my friend says do I
look fat in this yeah Dan comes up to
you and says do I look found this you
say yes because even if even if he
doesn't yeah but my my what why my wife
if she said do I look fat in this I know
I would say what would I say or what
about no that's this is that's not
better her thing's better what if
Kristen said do you still think I'm hot
well I would say yes but I do think
she's hot right and if you didn't think
she was hot
I would I would say yes because thank
you that's my because I know she's hot
right okay but if you know that woman's
out then then this guy should obviously
say yes but that's what I said in the
beginning is that she is hot he was he's
with her but your opinion of that
doesn't really matter because it's this
guy
so so bottom line is no matter what even
if what we're saying is not true you
have to lie that's what you're saying
uh yeah okay about that you don't have
to be a liar but when you're at when
someone asks you point blank that you're
in a relationship do you still think I'm
hot
you don't say ah I still think you're
cute I mean what the [__] is wrong right
but this okay this is advice for the guy
so we're saying with the advice for the
girl is here's the deal wait here's what
it seemed like she was asking though is
that am I right or am I crazy to feel a
little hurt by that yeah the answer is
no you're not crazy at all because she
said yeah no a [__] no you're totally in
the right is my is my answer to you but
go ahead um also here's the other thing
for the dude if she's like I can't she I
kind of jokingly just said like do you
still think I'm hot dude kind of
jokingly just say yeah right you know
what I'm saying right right right yeah
it's going to world baby right right
just keep it in the same tone right yeah
you need a lot of carbs
no I think uh yeah that's crazy you're
totally right to have your feelings a
little bit hurt don't let him like
Gaslight you about it though if it
actually hurt your feelings then like
you're allowed to have your feelings
hurt yeah because I would imagine if you
you're worried that if you said it hurt
my feelings you'd be like no come on
like that you know maybe not
let's take this outside dude I think
that
um I think that these are some of the
best submissions that we've ever gotten
yeah okay next
yeah I do I think these are some of the
best submissions we've ever gotten like
in a row in one episode yeah these are
good so much pressure on the next one so
we'll see what happens check this one
out okay
Dustin Diamond is alive uh Colin because
I got this issue uh it's kind of a
health issue
nothing serious well it could be serious
I quit smoking cigarettes like two years
ago it's been two years since I've had a
cigarette yeah like you know I've had
one or two within those two years
just like a social like one or two
um
so I can't say I've been clean two years
also I do vape
kind of like the main topic is I want to
quit vaping because I feel like
cigarettes have been along around long
enough where people know what's wrong
yeah and like what it'll do to you and
then I feel like vaping is kind of like
so new that they're discovering all
these terrible things
at first it was like I it sounded like a
healthy alternative sure get it but now
you know should I just stick to the Zaza
like just straight up [__] Mary Jane
all the way yeah yeah looking like this
all day that's been around for a long
time too uh what do you guys think let
me know
before we even get into the thing
that you are a that's the worst outfit
I've ever seen on anyone it look he
looks like Screech but a hippie hippie
Screech dude it's the the the the the
shirt isn't so bad but with the combo yo
bro
it also looks like The Sideburns weren't
a part of his head or his hair wasn't a
part of his head what I'm saying is the
sidebirds didn't go with the hair yeah
separate of the headband made it very
confusing it looks like the sideburns
and the glasses and the headbands were
all together and you put it on it once
yes yes yes there you go and you're a
bald guy and you just put on your outfit
yeah all right so anyway we got that out
of the way change it change no it's all
right it's fine we love you bud do you
have something say for real no you go
first you had something okay yeah uh so
is the thing that you just need to be
smoking something because those three
things are not similar obviously
cigarettes are similar to vaping smoking
weed is not similar to smoking
cigarettes so is it if but but what if
you if you if what you are asking is
it is the same to you what should you
smoke the answer is weed yeah because
you never heard of somebody getting lung
cancer right for marijuana why because
there's no [__] taurine I think it
could happen but and there's no
poisonous chemicals in it unless you've
got some shitty bag but if you're part
of the store you're not going to get
that so yeah if it's all the same to you
yeah just smoke weed you don't vape and
you know don't smoke cigarettes
and smoke weed that's very very simple
yeah if that's the question that's the
answer yeah and and uh and and uh
uh if you know look if you're one of
those guys that has to smoke weed every
day then that's really annoying if you
got to smoke something all every day
then you got to smoke weed all day that
sucks but also
because of the smoke no because it just
is so annoying when somebody's just high
all the time but also
look at you yeah he's high all the time
you smoke weed anyway anyone's anyone
who sees you is gonna think you're you
you have weed in your pocket or in your
headband or in your body yeah yeah and
so you might as well smoke it that'd be
like if I dress up as a ninja and
someone's like oh my God help those guys
are beating me up and I was just like oh
man sorry dude I don't know how to do
that everybody always thinks that be
like but you're yeah yeah but you're
dressed up as a you have size
and ninja stars oh dude but your Katana
ah is that what that is
he's got weed yeah you're already there
you know so smart
I've gone through phases where I was
high as [__] every single day how did it
hard and a mother for a couple years
where I was just blowing it up
okay hard in the [__] what's
that who's that that's not a dog no the
other one was Nate Dogg yeah small weed
every day higher than the [__]
is Nate Dogg dead
damn Nate dead no [__] no no Nate Dogg
was so ill yeah I do not speak of him
that way you're making a joke I know but
he was dope but Nate dead
[Music]
no no no no
dog oops okay
more
what's up Matt what's up I'm in the
angle falling down so lately I've been
going to the beach and
I've had people sit right next to me no
or directly in front of me absolutely
not
um I don't know why they have the entire
Beach that's insane it's like I joined a
family
does that bother you and if you were to
say something what would you say to them
exactly what you said um and also when
I'm playing loud music on speaker
I know so you already said the right
thing this is a big beach could you
please sit somewhere else or even why
are you sitting here this is why are you
trying to make me uncomfortable because
the only thing that a sane person here's
here's why ultimately everyone should
know this is the wrong thing to do but
here's how we would know if we didn't
know already you would go and you'd be
about to sit down and you'd think
well I I even if I want to sit right
next to that girl that's probably going
to make her really uncomfortable yeah so
with that line of thinking those people
are bypassing that thought and not
caring so ultimately they don't care if
they're making you uncomfortable
therefore you can be as rude as you want
to them because they don't give a [__]
that is true but they do not care about
your level that's true but it's not
necessarily what the people are thinking
when they're sitting next to her right
and if they're not if they're not
thinking that then they're [__] crazy
and be careful so that's also not
necessarily true because there is one
more thing do you think there's either
there's one more possibility so what
what's a besides besides totally
disrespectful or crazy what else is
there
the person that's like oh I like people
she likes people let's let's join
you know that person that's the worst of
the bunch I mean that's a horrible I
don't know that's an annoying person if
that person exists then that's even more
dangerous be careful because that's just
wrong to be that way but here's the
other thing about life people gravitate
towards people right so if you're going
to the beach and it's like oh I would go
separate right yeah so would I and so
whatever if it's a guy sitting next for
you you get why yeah but then that's
just gonna make her uncomfortable I
understand that but guys are dumb though
and I guess what I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah that guy's dumb but then also if
you're going to beach alone in a
swimsuit like that and I don't know if
she's the mayor of Maysville but maybe
she's the mayor of naysville right
naysville where did that come from again
I don't know
these means you know I know what Nays
I've deduced what Nays means what the
hell did we talk we used to do that
right the mayor of naysville you've
that's something you have said before
it's not you yeah
it's quite Brandon goody dude
oh yeah because it would say mayonnaise
and then we said the mayor what's the
mayonnaise thing is that Brandon goody
yeah I don't know dude he's your friend
I'm happy to do this thing what's that
stenones I don't know that's him
what's that from
was that John Shara I can't tell you
I'll tell you after what uh okay okay
mayor of Nashville okay oh he knows yeah
dude it's private so anyway
um
so anyway if she's a mayor of naysville
and that means you know what it means by
now uh then you get why the guys want to
sit next to her but here's what you do
cute though too like it doesn't we don't
need it I'm joking joking her face is
great we don't know about anything
better faces only ever faced anyway dude
we're getting the Canton today deep seas
here but what what what we're what we're
what you can do is when they uh
when they you stay till they leave when
they leave you walk with them and get in
their car yeah and when they say what
are you doing you say well obviously
we're family
Santa Claus yeah the whole Beach
oh
I mean coming I have a good idea though
for real it's a little bit it's the same
idea but you follow them in their car
see what car they're getting into get in
your car follow them follow them home
sneak in behind them as they open the
door with their key wait in another room
until they get in bed and then get in
bed with them I mean and say when they
act weird say oh I'm sorry I thought we
were married because only married people
sit this close together wow such a drawn
out good night my sweetheart good night
my sweet husband but they're gonna like
it dude yeah true
yeah yeah so yeah so we'll take it back
I take it back yeah if it's a woman
though you can do that yeah uh I think
that that's very annoying yeah I think I
I do kind of feel like a beach is a
place where you bring a a Boombox kind
of scenario stereo too but I also think
it's very annoying if the she's saying
what about people who bring their music
she had music oh well she's about she's
playing loud music and they still come
yes this is what she's saying oh well
right I mean no I thought that she was
like also what about this oh either way
either way you bring your your your your
your [__] Bose pill whatever the [__]
beat pill is and you play it to where
it's not crazy loud if you're around
people and uh and if you play any louder
than that he pays right maybe bring
something that smells really bad do
something that's like rude I want you to
be rude I don't usually recommend
rudeness but like that is such a No-No
that is like there are certain things
that just are so blatantly breaking the
social contract that we all silently
agree to when we got in into the world
that's one of them so I want you to be
rude I want you to bring like a stink
bomb or or something that will take
bombing yeah something something really
bad and just naughty be naughty remember
the stink bombs they were so bad we just
throw them and they break remember the
Itchy stuff itchy powder oh yeah
on your back and you were like
also to Vince Brown I pretended that uh
uh Cody's dog food was beef jerky and it
didn't go that well because he ate it
and he was just like is this dog food
and I was like yeah dude he's like your
name was Vince Braun that's a pretty
balliness that'd be like if your name
was Kevin Macon that's uh oh I didn't
even think about that wow wow wow wow
because you know him very well and I
don't yeah right right right my name is
Tom booze right right right right you
know Nicholas rage
yeah
Vincent tenafrio Brad wow now we have to
definitely bleep that out also when you
said
and please no and bleep that one out
French
do we have another one or what
Kenny G hey Matt and Chris uh Hannah
here calling in just with a small advice
question basically I have always wanted
to Vlog I know it's a cringe no no no
but I've been scared too because I'm shy
and a little bit awkward
but um a lot of my close friends say
that I should just do it for me have fun
like whatever it doesn't matter what
other people think like kind of block
the negativity
um spin movement mentality I guess but I
just wanted to know like
should I do it um I'm not trying to gain
anything financially out of it I have a
job but
I guess I don't know if I should face my
fear or if because there's just so much
content out there like why even bother
yeah but that's
um yeah so just want to know what you
guys think love the show uh love tuning
in so thank you thank you two things
I'll go first before you even said
anything about vlogging or putting
yourself out there I was thinking
you have a very like listenable voice
and so to answer I think that speaks to
your question which is that if you're
gonna have a vlog I think that would be
a good thing because your voice is a
good one go ahead I mean look I don't
know what kind of Vlog she wants to do
but he she's a very sweet person a very
likable person you know and her nails
are sick yeah like she's got I mean dude
anyone can have a vlog but here's the
thing dude you saying well everyone does
it everyone has a Content out there
that's defeatist you don't drop that
immediately because if you want to do it
you should do it yes and you're not you
this is like a thing I'm shy but this is
going to help you if you're shy it's
gonna help you
put it out there also here's the other
thing too here's something you couldn't
do you could do one upload it and and
and either have a private link or or you
know send it to friends or you can just
put one out there and put it up and see
what happens and um here's another thing
you can do you can put one up and never
check the comments which is very hard to
do or view count or view count but you
just put it up why do you want to do it
right you know ask yourself why you want
to do it here's you don't want to get
anything Financial here's the other
thing though and it's true that there's
so much content and so much of it is
drivel and most of it is just noise but
think about this
what if your favorite podcast or
whatever Vlog I don't know
think about like your favorite thing
that you listen to or watch online what
if those people were like oh there's too
much
there's too much stuff out there I don't
really want to do it that would you
would you personally would suffer that
bad decision so think of it that way
yeah what if we didn't do this podcast
because we thought that then you would
be sadder right right right right she
wouldn't care if like you didn't do
congratulations this one would make her
really sad because this one's good well
that's very rude my [__] is popping
though a dad
um you're a very sweet person you should
start you should start the Vlog there's
what's the harm in it yeah what's the
harm in it she's shy she's she's
insecure she thinks she's gonna like be
stupid or feel stupid but whatever but
that's the take yeah the only way you're
gonna get over that anyway is to just do
that because like there's no way around
it you got to go through it yeah and you
want to get rid of that fear anyway so
if for no other reason
to get over the fear that you have yeah
you should do it if you're not growing
you're dying and if you're not doing
this you're not growing so don't die
well doctor okay no I just feel like you
should do it yeah and also it's like
she's immediately likable yeah you know
so like it's you know I thought that
before you but yeah oh okay well so I
thought she was like a little before you
thought she was like that's fine so what
my point is that I'm
a bigger fan of hers than you are she's
got nice hair Kenny G [__] nice Kenny
G hair she definitely puts Kenny G to
shame yeah well now at this point and
also she's not gonna go but I mean is he
bald well yeah I think he's receding oh
he's going back there no
and then he says what I said Kenny going
going gone
is it he looks like the guy in Color Me
bad and I dare anyone to try to prove me
otherwise I dare anyone to try to prove
to me that's a guy yes it's going
backwards but Uncle Denny dude that guy
Kenny G
well no not the black black guy
I'm saying even the white guy doesn't
look anything like him the white guys
Kenny G did you say Uncle Denny Uncle
Denny
looks like Kenny G he doesn't look like
him in that picture but the simple fact
that you said which guy that's how much
he does it looks like you're dumb but
that's how much
okay stop clicking on that one though
you know
yeah
Kenny G is a pimp though dude I guess
man I mean like I don't how would I know
can you do the poop no don't do that how
would you know Kenny G's a pimp how
would you know Kenny G is anything
honestly even a good food I'll tell you
why I'll tell you why what I think
people like Michael Bolton people used
to make fun of Kenny G yeah and Kenny G
plowed right through it and was like I
do not give a [__] okay that's good yes
and he didn't change his style he didn't
change the kind of music he plays he
didn't change his hair Michael Bolton
was like I'm gonna cut my hair and then
start making fun of myself
[__] that dude it's true he's a real
Jeep he's a real Kenny G more gangster
Michael Bolton is what he is yeah kind
of gangster yeah because Kenny G was
like you're gonna keep making fun of me
that's cool yeah
[Music]
it's George Michael but that's George no
no kg does that for sure he plays Carlos
he covers that for sure well I mean he
covers everything I mean he should but
no
plow that's Pour some sugar on me oh wow
okay hey he doesn't do that just the
lyrics you know yeah no doubt I mean
that does not surprise me at all yeah
but that's cool
uh yeah Kenny G is the original [__]
careless Whisperer
so loud you know I couldn't care about
this whisper if you talk louder maybe
I'll care about it so bad
Ghost Whisper is a really good song dude
George Michael very good dude
yeah rest in peace
dog are just in heaven well I mean
Nate's dog's like not hanging out with
them because you know Nate Dogg is not
down with that gay [__] but I'm just
saying
this is for you George
I got this for you
for all you [__] George Michael fans
out there who are from bathrooms door
open or whatever you did that yeah was
not what he did he got arrested for
jerking off now
Dave was one of the guys
what's happening what was that
what was that
what was it
take on there's different ways to do it
you ever watch that [__] no not that I
go on foreign
[Applause]
why is it so [__] wrong
what's with the air you're not even
coming to the area plan on it
what if
what if you died right after this right
now and this was the last thing you ever
did
I get a car wreck this is the last bit
of Comedy I ever did
oh [__]
oh wow plan on and on and on maybe a
pizza making a pizza
this is the best this is the best
podcast what the [__] [__] goddamn
dude
this is the best podcast man I don't
these [__] idiots out there with
podcasts this one's the best you know
it's funny because last episode you
literally said it's the worst podcast
but [__] it
fluctuating feelings if you wanted one
advice session with me your boy
baby baby
go to krista.com get your tickets I'm
going to be in Austin I'm going to be in
uh uh Austin I'm gonna be in uh all
these places man it's gonna be crazy man
oh wow doing my special he's directing
it so come on out dude
um and also where else am I gonna be I
don't even know dude you got a question
check the link in the description below
or go to watch lifeline.com you want
that life on merch go to
lifelinemerch.com I'm so tired after
laughing so hard like you too oh man
hello hello
[Music]